club de trappes a organisé ce dimanche
matin la deuxième manche se déchaînent
j'ai espoir et avenir de la région ile
de france
un rendez vous qui a regroupé sur la
base nautique de l'île des loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines une dizaine de
clubs et plus de 200 jeunes de la
catégorie minimes à la catégorie junior
au programme des courses d'orientation
des courses en ligne pour les
participants confirmés ou novices
on écoute les réactions au micro de tv
78 qu'on découvre plein de personnes et
on peut se concentrer à des meilleurs et
des moins bien pour m'amuser déjà toi
aussi pour gagner parce que j'ai c'est
bien d'avoir des confins des
compétitions ça permet de le voir comme
on évolue au fil du temps jeu ça permet
aussi aux nouveaux
nouveaux jeunes qui en retirant dans les
clubs d'essayer de nouveaux bateaux
comme du canoë ou de la course en ligne
ou du bateau des centres fin ils peuvent
essayer plusieurs choses